The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseware
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseware
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Today, since
the notes for this
didn't exist until last
night, I made copies for you.
I will do a little
more revisions
on what appears on the web.
But this is a really
interesting and important topic.
And so I think it's
important that I give
a little bit of extra guidance.
So we're going to talk
about what's in a spectrum.
But in a very
special sense, we're
going to be talking about
wave packet dynamics.
And how do we understand what to
expect in wave packet dynamics?
And how do we approach it?
And so let's begin
talking about this.
So you already know
from my lectures
earlier, if you have a time
independent Hamiltonian,
how do you create a wave packet?
I mean, after this
exam performance,
I want some insights.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] the
individual eigenstates.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So you use a short pulse.
And you create some kind
of linear combination.
Usually, if you're not
making eigenstates,
that's a complication.
And why would you
want to do that?
And the reason you do it is
because these wave packets are
going to move.
And particles move.
Your instincts are
about particles moving.
And there are rules for
the particles moving,
which are mostly what
you have in your head.
But there are some
special stuff that has
to do with quantum mechanics.
And so I'd like to
build from the bottom.
And so I want you to be able to
understand wave packets moving
on a diatomic surface.
And then we'll make a step
into slightly more complicated
situations.
If we have a diatomic, we
have a potential curve.
And we have an initial state.
And that initial
state in V equals
0 gives us access to a
range of vibrational levels
in the upper state.
And if we have a
short pulse, we can
create some kind of a
wave packet involving
a linear combination of
these vibrational levels.
So suppose you had a polyatomic,
3N minus 6 vibrational modes.
So what would you do to go
from a diatonic molecule
to a polyatomic molecule?
Initially, you want to
do something simple that
doesn't involve anything
that's especially new.
So what would you say about
dynamic diatomic polyatomic
surface where there's 3N
minus 6 as opposed to 1
vibrational modes?
What kind of a wave packet
would you do, would you create?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: We had
Franck-Condon bright modes
and Franck-Condon dark modes.
So it sounds like you're
right on the verge
of saying something profound.
So say it.
AUDIENCE: You're just going
to have lot more coordinates.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
You're going to have
more coordinates.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: So you will
create a wave packet
on the Franck-Condon
bright modes.
And if there's more than one
Franck-Condon bright mode,
the wave packet will
do just like what
it would do on a
diatomic molecule,
except you might have two
different frequencies.
OK, well, there's
additional complications.
And that is, even a
diatomic molecule,
we don't have harmonic motion.
So the wave packet, because
of diagonal anharmonicity,
will dephase.
But the center of
the wave packet
will continue to
move at the average
of the vibrational frequencies
for all these modes.
You know that.
And so in a polyatomic
molecule, maybe there's two,
maybe there's three
Franck-Condon bright modes.
And the wave packet will have
several different components
on the different
Franck-Condon bright modes.
And they'll be diagonal
anharmonicities.
And they will dephase and
possibly do interesting things.
So now, polyatomic molecules
can do something else.
Because there are, in fact,
3N minus 6 vibrational modes.
And there's anharmonic
couplings between the modes.
So if you created some wave
packet or set of wave packets
in a polyatomic molecule, there
will be anharmonic interactions
between modes.
And what you will
have is the appearance
of wave packets in the
Franck-Condon dark modes
with their own frequencies.
So this is starting
to get interesting.
Because you hit this molecule.
And it starts
revealing its secrets.
Where you had
Franck-Condon dark modes,
they're not going
to talk to you.
But now, because of the
anharmonic couplings, they do.
And then with a
diatomic molecule,
we might have an excited state.
And it might be crossed
by a repulsive state
or crossed by
another bound state.
But if you have a wave packet
operating on this bound state,
it's going to be crossing
through this region.
What's so special about
where curves cross?
You know this, too.
If you're in this state
and at this point,
you have this much momentum.
And if you're on this curve at
that point, you have the same.
So you have two rapidly
oscillating things
with the same spatial
oscillation frequency.
And so there's a possibility
that the wave packet
can leak from this curve,
from the bound curve,
to the repulsive curve.
And there are all sorts
of things of that nature.
I'm going to talk about
all of that today.
And one of the
things-- the reason I
made these notes is
because I've always
wanted to say something
about the Landau-Zener model
for crossing between
different potential curves.
And we talked a little bit
before about driving too fast
on a curvy road.
Do you stay on it or
do you hit the tree?
And that's basically
this picture of--
you have two curves that can
cross or they could do this.
This is the adiabatic
representation,
which is amenable to quantum
chemical calculations.
And this crossing curve is
the diabatic representation,
which chemists like
because the electronic wave
functions don't change as
a function of internuclear
distance.
And so the issue is, when
you have crossing curves
or avoided crossing
curves, how do you
understand what
the wave packet is
going to do with those points?
And that's the point
of this lecture.
And there are two experiments
done by Ahmed Zewail's research
group which illustrate many
of the effects of wave packets
and avoided crossings.
And so the question
is, how do we
observe this kind of
evolution of the wave packet?
What kind of
experiments do we do?
If we're talking
about motion, we're
probably not interested
in the frequency domain.
Although, you can get
a lot of information
from the frequency
domain that enables
you to understand what you
might see in the time domain.
And one thing about frequency
domain experiments--
when you have a
molecule, which has
3N minus 6 vibrational
modes, like benzene has 30,
the vibrational
density of states
increases rapidly with
excitation energy.
So rapidly that,
above the region
of the fundamentals, the
highest frequency fundamentals,
they're no longer resolvable
vibrational levels.
The density of states is
on the order of a billion
per wave number.
And you're going to be
asking different kinds
of experimental questions to
say, do I understand what's
going on in even a molecule as
small, from your point of view,
as benzene, big from
my point of view.
OK, so we're interested
in mechanism.
Why do things happen?
What makes them happen?
And how do we
construct an experiment
that reveals mechanism?
And how do we interpret
those sorts of experiments?
And the Zewail experiments
are beautiful examples
of revealing mechanism,
which is more complicated--
well, more revealing than
what you might expect.
For example, suppose you excite
a molecule and it breaks.
Well, how did it break?
Did it just break?
Or was there some motion
preceding the breaking where
the molecule arranged itself
to receive this photon
and do something with it?
And it makes fragments.
And what are the fragments?
What state are the fragments in?
There are all sorts
of stuff there.
And that's mechanism.
And it's not just the
breaking of a molecule
and getting from the width
of a spectral feature
how fast that breaking occurred.
There's things that
happen in that time.
OK.
So we need to talk about
diabatic versus adiabatic.
And so if you did a quantum
chemical calculation--
and you can.
Because you still have
access to the Athena cluster.
Or is your membership expired?
AUDIENCE: We should
always have access to it.
PROFESSOR: OK.
Well, you do a calculation
using the computer programs.
And they're basically
clamped nuclei.
And that's just because you
want to reduce the complexity
of the calculation.
It's an impossible calculation
anyway to do exactly.
And if we say, let's
keep the heavy particles
from moving around,
we just solve
the electronic
Schrodinger equation,
well, then we get what we call
an adiabatic potential energy
surface, or one for
each electronic state.
And well, if we
clamp the nuclei,
molecules don't hit
the nuclei clamp.
We have to unclamp them.
And the effect unclamping leads
to some perturbation term, H1.
And so when we solve the clamped
nuclei Schrodinger equation,
we don't have vibrations.
We don't have rotations.
And so one of the things
we don't know about
is partial derivatives with
respect to nuclear coordinates,
which we have the nuclear
kinetic energy, which
is the second derivative.
And when you have a
second derivative,
you can apply one derivative
to the nuclear part
of the wave function
and one derivative
to the electronic part.
Or you can apply both.
And so the electronic
wave function you get is--
you get a wave function,
which is an explicit function
of the electron positions
and parametrically dependent
on internuclear distances
or nuclear geometry.
Well, that's there.
And this nuclear kinetic
energy term, which is present,
is going to operate on these
guys and lead to trouble.
Or maybe not, depending on what
the potential curves look like
and what the their problem is.
But certainly, this
nuclear kinetic energy
can operate on these
functions and give something
that we have to
at least consider.
So this guy has secrets
embedded in it that we're
going to have to look at.
And they're going
to be surprises.
So let's think about diatomics.
Because with diatomics,
most of the things
you're going to encounter
in polyatomic molecules
have examples that you can
understand really clearly.
So suppose there are two
electronic states that
cross or do something.
And we can have a
picture like this.
So the calculation
you do will give you
these avoided crossing
potential curves.
Well, why do they
avoid each other?
If you have two states
of the same symmetry,
they can perturb each other.
The Hamiltonian is
totally symmetric.
Any kind of term
in the Hamiltonian
that is totally
symmetric can cause
interactions between states
of the same symmetry.
Now, many of these terms
of the same symmetry--
totally symmetric terms
in the Hamiltonian--
are excluded when
we do a calculation.
Because we can.
One is spin R.?
But there are things that could
affect the states belonging
to these two potential curves.
And so there are going to be
interactions between states
of the same symmetry.
And this is the place.
So you have the ab
initio calculation.
You get these curves.
And you can see that
there is some coordinate
at which the difference between
potential curves is a minimum.
Nature tips its hand.
These avoided crossings
that are really important.
And it tells you-- the quantum
chemical calculations tell you
two things.
They tell you the
internuclear distance
at which the crossing occurs.
And let's call this one--
let's have several
names for these curves.
OK, I have to--
so we can call this 2, 1,
1, 2 plus plus minus minus.
I have two sets of labels.
So let's say that
the 2 and 1 describe
the electronic character of
this state, the kind of thing
that the chemists care about.
And plus and minus
as upper and lower.
And that's what you get
from quantum chemistry.
And so the quantum
chemistry gives you
the place at which
these two curves
have this minimum separation.
And they have the plus
at RC minus V minus at RC
is equal to 2 H 12.
You know from
perturbation theory
that, if you have two
levels which are degenerate
and they're interacting
by some coupling term,
the separation will end up
being twice the matrix element.
So nature gives
you this and this
from which you can construct
the crossing curves,
the curves that chemists like.
So even though quantum
chemistry doesn't
know about diabatic
curves, it tells you
how you could construct them.
And now, there's
two limiting cases.
We can have a very
weak interaction.
And so the curves get
really close together.
Or we can have a very
strong interaction
and get something like this.
So these are the two limits.
And it turns out that the way
you would handle these two
limits is experimentally
and theoretically profoundly
different.
Why?
This term, the nuclear
kinetic energy term,
does terrible things here.
Because when it operates on
the electronic wave function,
it says, the electronic
wave function
is changing rapidly
in this region.
And so if we're going to try
to set up a Hamiltonian that
describes the energy
levels of these two states,
because of this
term, there will be
enormous couplings between the
vibrational levels of the two
states.
And as a result, H0, the thing
that ignores those coupling
effects, will bear almost no
resemblance to the observed
energy level structure.
To get from these
kinds of curves
to the observed energy
levels is a lot of work.
And it's work that people
who use pre-written computer
programs are ill prepared to do.
The spectrum will not
be predicted in any way
by this, unless you do a
huge matrix of interactions
between vibrational levels
of the different electronic
states.
And when you have a matrix
element, which is large
compared to the
differences between levels,
you can't use
perturbation theory.
You have to
diagonalize a matrix.
And usually, when you
diagonalize a matrix,
the eigenvalues are
a bit of a surprise.
Over here, the
electronic wave function
doesn't change very rapidly.
And so we have no problem
of the interactions
among the vibrational
levels of these two states.
And so the adiabatic
representation
provides a good zero order
picture of the energy levels.
And there's a
little bit of stuff
that you can add
to improve the fit.
So when you have what's called
a weakly avoided crossing,
it tells you that the
adiabatic representation
is the wrong one.
But when you have a
strongly avoided crossing,
well, it's the right one.
Because all of the effects of
this repulsion between the two
states are included in your
zero order Hamiltonian.
Whereas here, none are.
And you say, well,
I could just go
cruising through this region.
And I go fast through it.
And I don't notice
the bad effects.
Well, we'll see.
OK.
So now, if we had a diabatic
representation like this,
well, diabatic curves can cross.
In fact, that's the whole point.
We want them to cross.
Because we'd like to keep
track of electronic character 1
and electronic character 2.
And so I'm just going
to use this here.
OK.
But the really
annoying thing is,
when we did an
initial calculation,
we clamped the nuclei.
We said there are certain terms
in the exact Hamiltonian we're
going to push aside
and consider later.
But for the diabatic
picture, well, it's
clearly there's some term in
the electronic Hamiltonian
that we'd like to turn off.
But there isn't one.
It's all or nothing.
There is nothing
you can identify
in the electronic
Hamiltonian that enables
the two curves to cross.
So it's not that
it's a bad idea.
It's just there is no simple
way of dealing with this.
Now sometimes, we
have the Hamiltonian.
And we have, say, the
spin orbit Hamiltonian.
And this is something
we could turn off.
But that's gilding the lily.
I am a spin orbit aficionado.
So I could deal with this.
But if we don't say there
are specific, named,
small terms in the
electronic Hamiltonian,
there is no way we can get
the diabatic limit directly.
You have to use a trick.
So let's draw a picture now,
which illustrates the trick.
And we're almost
ready to start talking
about Zewail's experiment.
So here I'm going to draw.
OK.
So the adiabatic curves are
the ones that don't cross.
And The.
Dash lines are the
diabatic curves.
And we know RC and H12.
Or at least we know H12 at
that internuclear distance.
And it's a reasonable
thing to say, well,
let's let it not change
with internuclear distance.
And let's make some
other approximation.
We can say the
diabatic curves are
linear in the region
of the curve crossing.
We can always-- especially when
the adiabatic picture is bad,
that curve crossing is
very, very compressed.
And it's not a big
step to say, OK,
over this relatively small
range of internuclear distance
and energy, we're going to
approximate the diabatic curves
as linear.
And so we know the exact
Hamiltonian, whatever it is,
be gotten from.
OK.
So here, we have what's
available from quantum
chemistry.
These are the potential
curves for the upper and lower
adiabatic states.
And here we have a
potential curve for state 1
and a potential curve
for state 2 at H12.
And a unitary transformation
of this matrix
has to be equal that matrix.
Well, we don't know these.
But we're going to reduce
them to one number,
the slope at the crossing.
And so we have one number
here, one number here.
And all of a sudden,
we have enough
to iteratively determine the
difference between the slopes
by fitting to the observed
adiabatic potentials.
And this is basically
how it's done.
Now, people who do these
calculations for a living
have a much encrusted
picture of how they do this.
But this is basically
what's going on.
Because people do want
the diabatic picture.
And a lot of insight is gained
from the diabatic picture.
OK.
So if we're going to be
approaching a spectrum where
we have energy levels or an
experiment where we learn
something about
the dynamics, we're
going to want to think about
this problem with two limits--
weakly avoided and
strongly avoided.
And completely different
methods for dealing
with both spectroscopic
and dynamical information
are appropriate
for the two limits.
OK.
Landau-Zener-- this is
a model for saying, OK,
what is the probability of going
for one curve to the other?
And so we have a formula,
which you can derive.
I don't recommend it.
Because derivations are things
you do when you need it.
And then you forget them.
But I do want to give you
a sense of what's in it.
So we're going from one
adiabatic state to another.
And the probability is 1
minus e to the minus pi gamma.
The important parameter
is gamma, right?
Everything in this.
OK.
And so P12 is small
when gamma is--
well, we want this to be 1--
so when gamma is small.
And P12 is large--
now, I just want to make
sure that I have it--
yeah, when gamma is large.
Now, what's gamma?
Gamma is expressed--
and this is what
you would derive if you were
going to do this for real life.
Because you would never accept
somebody else's speculation,
you derive it yourself.
So V12 squared-- that's
the matrix element.
That's half the gap between
the diabatic curves.
And it's over H bar
velocity S1 minus S2.
This is the difference in
slopes of the diabatic curves
at the crossing point.
This is the velocity
of the particle going
through the crossing point.
And you can, of course,
get the velocity
from the momentum
divided by the mass.
And so all of this
stuff is there.
And so gamma is
small when V is large
and when S1 is
approximately equal to S2.
Well, if the slopes
are nearly equal,
that's a strongly
avoided crossing, right?
And V is large-- well, if
you're going through a bend
in the road and
it's too fast, well,
then you're not going to--
yes, you're not going to
be able to make the curve.
So anyway, this is the physical
basis behind Landau-Zener.
And it contains the
connections to the stuff
you have from your
picture of the potentials.
And this is basically how
you organize a Zewail type
experiment, which I've
got to talk about now.
You have those notes already
on Zewail electronically.
So I didn't make
copies of them for you.
So you're going
to have to accept
what I'm doing without looking
at notes for this part,
unless you have them
already printed out.
So Zewail had the 1999
Nobel Prize in chemistry.
And it was really special.
Because usually, these things
are divided three ways.
He got the whole damn thing.
And this was because he offered
something that we really want.
We want to have an idea of,
what is the mechanism by which
dynamical processes occur?
In other words, we're
not just getting rate.
But we're getting, what
are the nuclei doing?
And how does the
motion of the nuclei
affect the rate of the process?
AUDIENCE: I think you want
S1 is very different than S2.
PROFESSOR: That's quite likely.
And I'm very poor with logic.
Let's see.
So I want you to decide
for yourself, OK?
And let me just--
OK.
So this is an example of
a pump/probe experiment.
So the pump pulse at t
equals 0 starts things.
And the probe pulse at t
equals tau asks the question,
has the wave packet
gotten to what's called
the OCR, the optically
coupled region?
In other words, you
create a wave packet
and you have a probe
which can tell you
the time at which the wave
packet passes through where
you're probing it.
And this is really neat.
And it is, I think, the
essence of how Zewail created
a really simple experiment
using the crude technology that
was available at the time to ask
the kind of question he needed
to ask.
Now, I didn't like
this whale experiment
when it first came out.
Well, because I'm a frequency
domain spectroscopist.
And I don't really
care about dynamics,
except how it's encoded in
the frequency domain spectrum.
So this is completely different.
But anyway, so now, I want
to describe the essence
of what he did, and why it
worked, and what it reveals.
All right, and so I want
to pick a blackboard.
So there are two
experiments that he did.
One was dissociation of I-CN.
And the other was
dissociation of sodium iodide.
Now, one thing to
notice is we've
got a big heavy atom in here.
So that means the vibrational
frequencies are low.
That means that, with
a not too short pulse,
you could create a
coherent superposition.
When you think
about what you would
need to create a
coherent superposition
of vibrational levels, different
by the canonical 1,000 wave
numbers of a vibration, you
realize that that experiment
was only doable
fairly recently when
you have on the order of a few
femtosecond time resolution.
What Zewail did-- he had maybe
a 100 femtosecond or maybe only
a picosecond.
And so he had to
have a heavy atom.
For I-CN, the beautiful thing
about I-CN is there's CN here.
CN is a diatomic molecule that
has a very convenient spectrum.
And so we're asking
the question,
how does the presence of the
iodine affect the CN spectrum?
Because the CN is
going to give us
the signal in this experiment.
So here is-- it's really neat.
This is a triatomic molecule.
But we always use one
dimensional pictures
to describe everything
that's going on.
And you can do that when the
one dimensional pictures are
each applicable
in separate times
or at separate aspects
of the experiment.
But it's another
beautiful example.
If Zewail had been attempting
to describe the full three
dimensional potential , the
pictures wouldn't have done
anything for anybody.
Because you would have to work
too hard to understand what
the pictures are telling you.
OK.
So we now have a
repulsive curve.
And we have another
OK.
So we have V equals 0.
And so we're exciting
a wave packet.
And because we have a few
vibrational levels that
are accessible with the
Franck-Condon principle from V
equals 0 and within
the necessary Fourier
transform of the
post duration, you
get a wave packet starting here.
OK.
So this wave packet is
going to be toodling along
at this energy.
I'm sorry it's going to be
moving on this potential.
But it has a definite energy.
OK.
And then you can probe it this
way, or this way, or this way.
And the important thing
is that these three places
at which you probe correspond to
different excitation energies.
It's saying that, as the
iodine atom is leaving--
these are transitions
between CN.
And in here, the iodine
atom is close to the CN.
And it is affecting
the bonding in the CN.
Over here, it's gone.
And the CN is free.
And what's happening is the
transition frequency changes
with time.
And so if he has the
probe pulse here,
well, then when the wave
packet reaches this point,
you get a response.
Before the wave packet gets
there, there is no exaltation.
So the OCR is defined--
the optically
coupled region-- it's
defined by the frequency,
the center frequency,
of the probe pulse.
So if we then look at--
OK, now, what's happening here?
When you excite
to this state, you
have CN electronically excited.
When you look at this
limit, you have CN
not electronically excited.
The CN A double pi x double
sigma plus transition
is one of the most studied
things in the atomic molecules.
And so it's known.
And like all transitions, the
intrinsic radiative lifetime
is on the order
of 10 nanoseconds.
So if we excite to
this state, we're
going to get a photon out.
But the lifetime of that
photon is 10 nanoseconds.
Are we going to
measure dynamics?
This is the beauty of the
experiment right here.
He catches the wave packet
at a particular position.
And he puts it in the bank.
And then eventually,
the CN flouresces.
We don't care anything
about when it flouresces
or what frequency
it flouresces at.
All we cared about is that--
if you're looking at
if the wave packet is
in the optically
coupled region, it
gets excited to this surface.
And then when it
chooses to say, I
got excited, here is my photon,
then you can create a plot of--
so versus time.
So you see nothing.
And then you get something at
the optically coupled region.
And you do a sequence
of experiments
where you vary where the
optically coupled region is
centered by adjusting the center
frequency of the probe laser.
So sorry.
I should really say, OK,
here is the intensity
of the fluorescence.
And here is the 1 over the
wavelength of the probe.
So this is related to
the energy of the probe.
And so you do a
series of experiments.
And you discover that the
wave packet reaches this.
And then you move that.
And you get another.
And so you get a picture.
So what do I want
to say about this?
So it basically is telling you
that, when the molecule breaks,
the frequency of
the CN excitation
is changing as a function of
the distance of the iodine atom
from the CN.
And so that's mechanism.
Now, it's really a
very crude mechanism.
But because it's
reduced to one question,
it's a function of one geometry.
But nobody's ever
be able to say they
observed this motion of the
wave packet in real time.
And here is where people
really get annoyed with Zewail.
Because he's looking at
real motion in real time.
And it ain't real.
He's probing one time at a time.
But it's still mechanism.
It's more than just looking
at when does something break.
What's the lifetime
of something?
There's more than
one thing going on.
Now, I really like
the next experiment.
And the next experiment
involves sodium iodide.
Now, if I were to
ask you, what is
the nature of sodium
iodide at equilibrium?
You'd say, it's probably ionic.
But because iodine
is at the bottom
as opposed to the top of
the periodic potential,
it's maybe a little
bit covalent.
So here is the ground
state potential.
And I just have to
make sure I understand
what I'm trying to do.
And here is an excited
state potential.
OK.
So what I've tried
is crossing curves.
Those are the diabatic curves.
Now, I've connected-- I should
do it with dotted lines.
Those are the adiabatic curves.
And so the question is,
suppose we create a wave packet
on this potential.
So it's created here.
And this wave packet
feels a force that way.
Because it's the gradient
of the potential.
It's a particle.
It's in a potential.
And it's going this way.
And then something
happens when it
goes through this
curve crossing region.
But what's going to happen?
I should just say
this is the ionic.
This is the covalent.
So this is NA plus plus I minus.
And this is NA plus I. When you
dissociate a neutral molecule,
you always get neutral atoms.
So there is a higher energy
limit where you can get ions.
And so even if you create
this wave packet here,
which is below the
threshold for making ions,
it only can leave by this path.
So what happens
is the wave packet
is going back and forth, back
and forth, back and forth.
And each time it crosses through
this region, it has to decide,
am I ionic or covalent?
And if I'm covalent,
I can leave.
And if I'm ionic, I'm stuck.
I've got to go back and try
again and again and again.
So this is where
Landau-Zener comes in.
Because what's happening
is the molecule
is addressing this ionic
covalent curve crossing.
And it's deciding each
time it goes through,
what is the probability
of being able to get out?
OK.
But then, there's
something else.
And that is, well,
what are we probing?
So we probe to an excited state.
And so this is where the
figures, even for this reduced
representation, are confusing.
But basically, you're probing
by exciting this sodium
atom to an excited state,
which puts it in the bank.
And it fluoresces
when it chooses to,
which is in 10 nanoseconds.
Because sodium's
radiative lifetime really
is about 10 nanoseconds.
And so how to describe this?
So you have a choice
of being able to excite
at the free sodium
transition frequency.
And then what you're only
seeing is these little packets
of sodium that make it out.
Or you can excite at a--
well, this is coming out wrong.
But if you excite
to the red of that,
you will only see
the sodium atoms
while they are still
close to the iodine.
And so there are two
sorts of signals you get.
One is you get a series
of pulses separated
by the round trip time--
the round trip
time is the period.
And so the period is related
the vibrational frequency.
And so each time
this packet goes
through the optically
coupled region--
I'm sorry-- goes through
the curve crossing region,
you get a little puff of sodium.
If you're exciting
so that you can
see only the free sodium,
well, then instead of this,
you see the signal,
another signal.
So you get little steps.
Each wave packet that makes it
out dies at the turning point.
And I'm way over time.
But this is really the--
so there's two pictures.
There is this sampling of
the wave packet each time
it goes through.
And there is the
delivery of the goods.
And again, the signal
is a slow signal.
But the pump/probe delay is
femtosecond time resolution.
And so it can reveal this
wave packet propagation.
So that's all I have
to say on the subject.
I think it's really beautiful.
I like it more and more
the more I understand it.
And the next lecture will
be on why gases condense.